sports now the raiders first las vegas
season
reached a conclusion today the silver
and black will not make the playoffs but
can reach a 500 record
for the first time in four years john
treach is here now with our season
finale highlights john
and the season finale just ended about
eight minutes ago in the history of
average football teams the raiders may
leave the universe in game day drama
suspense bowl finishes and moments that
catch you saying in all my days i've
never seen that before
john gruden finishing year three of
round two as a raider
and under the tutelage of mark davis las
vegas trying to finish
500 again for just the second time in
nine years derek carr dialing up fade
patterns
for the rest of time hopefully to darren
waller
and that's for your passing pleasure
just before half carr uncorking a bottle
of
six to brian edwards first career
touchdown by the rookie from south
carolina
fourth quarter this game got wild
raiders down seven
josh jacobs not satisfied already
crossed the 100
or the 1 000 yard threshold and not
finished 28 yards for number 28 game is
tied
broncos refusing to give up though drew
lock makes the best throw of his
professional career to jerry judy
the rookie from alabama runs like a
national champion
31-24 raiders get the ball back and
march a desperate drive fourth and goal
josh jacobs scores
but we don't play for ties in las vegas
raiders go for two
derek carr to darren waller las vegas
is victorious dramatically 32-31
in an unforgettable finale again for an
8-8 team this team keeps you
interested this is the raiders second
best finish again in nine years so an
accomplishment progress
the press conference is just beginning
we'll let you know what zany and
entertaining things john gruden has to
say
in our later newscasts